Now that we've completed all of the theory, let's jump in and start the exercise.
This is going to really reinforce the learning we've done so far
by allowing you to put a lot of the theory into practice.
To start with, I'm going to delete the example that we've been working
just so that we're working from a clean starting point.
And I'm going to create a new blueprint, and I'm going to select a blueprint class
I'm going to select actor. I'm going to name this blueprint BP underscore DAW.
And I'm going to double-click on this to start.
All we're looking to do in this setup is we're going to build a DAW actor
that when you walk up to it and push E, it's going to open.
When you push E again, it's going to close.
Relatively straightforward enough, but there's a fair amount of things
that can go into setting something like this.
So to start with, we're going to add some components to this blueprint.
So if you come up and push add and search for a static mesh,
you'll see that here at the bottom.
Once you add this in, can you name this DAW frame mesh?
Now, at the moment, we cannot see anything.
And that's because we haven't defined what static mesh we want to show.
So with the DAW frame mesh selected, come over to the static mesh in the details panel.
Click on the drop down and search for DAW.
Now we're going to select SM underscore DAW frame.
You should have this file if you selected to have the
starter content included in your project.
Now we can see the DAW frame here.
Let's add in another static mesh.
So if you push add and again search for static,
and let's call this DAW mesh.
And again in the details panel, I'm going to search for DAW,
and I'm going to select SM underscore DAW.
Now you'll see with this mesh, we actually have the pivot in the bottom left hand corner.
If I was to rotate this, we can see that this,
because the pivot is in the bottom left hand corner,
this is going to open and rotate like a DAW would rotate.
So all I'm going to do is change over to my translate,
and I'm going to fit this into the DAW frame.
Now in order to get this perfect, because you're going to find that it overlaps a little bit,
we'll need to come up to the snapping options.
In the top of the chart, and if you do a drop down to five,
you'll find that you can now move the mesh so that it sits perfectly within the frame.
Now there are a couple more elements that I want to add to this.
So the first one that I want to add is a light.
So I'm going to search for light.
I'm going to select a point light, and for this point light,
I'm just going to be using this in order to be able to show if the door is locked or unlocked.
So I'm going to move the light so it is just in front of the door like this,
and then with the light selected, I'm going to change the color to be green.
That means clear simple green. I'm just going to reduce red and blue down to zero.
Okay, so we now have a green light which is outside of the door.
Now there is one more element which I would like to to add to this,
and that is a box collision. So if we click on add and search for box,
and select box collision. Now if we drag this up and expand it so that it if it's a large area
around it, what we're looking to do is we're looking to define the area where you can
interact with the door. So we want it to be slightly larger than the door itself,
and just encapsulate it. Okay, so that's all of the elements that we're going to need
to create this blueprint. We have two meshes, the door frame and the door mesh.
We have a point light which we're going to be using to determine the light, to determine the
color, and we've got a box that will allow us to show when you have entered it or left it.
So we talked about events before. Now we only talked about the events which automatically
come with the engine, automatically come with the blueprint. However, what we can do is there is
a whole load of other events that you can either create or you can access off of the components.
Now if you would come to the box collision, if you right-hand click, you'll see that you have
an option for add event. We want to add two events. We want to add on component begin overlap
and on component end overlap. So if you select one and then come up to the box again,
right-hand click, add event, and then select the other. That should give you both of these
events. The on component begin overlap and the on component overlap. Now we're going to use this
in order to determine when someone has entered the box or when someone has left. So let's test
this out to start with. I'm going to drag off. I'm going to add a print string into here,
and this is going to say entered box, and I'm going to copy this, and I'm going to change
that to left box. Now if I compile and save and jump back to my map, and if I come over,
if I drag my blueprint into the world, I'm going to create an instance of this blueprint. Now I'm
going to rotate this so that it faces the player. I'm going to push play. Now I see my door,
and if I walk up to it, you can see that entered box has come up from the left-hand
side. If I've left, it's going to say left box. Now that's great because all we've got now
is we confirmed that this works. So you're going to delete these and jump in, and we're going to
put some more code on here. What I want to do is I want to enable and disable the input
for this actor. So at the moment this actor is unaware of any key presses that the player
might make. I don't want to get this to start listening to them. That way we can trigger an
event when a key is pressed. So I'm going to right-hand click. I'm going to get to the player
controller. You can see we have get player controller here, and it has an input pin of number,
but we only have one player in this game, so zero is going to return that. Fine. Now if I drag
off of the player controller and type enable, I'm going to get an option for enable input.
I'm going to do the same thing down here, and I'm going to type and add disable. And so
I'm going to connect this up, and I'm going to connect this one up here. So what we have here
is when we are entering the box, we are going to enable the input for this, and when we leave
the box we're going to disable the input. Now there is a problem that we've got with this,
and that is that the target is actually supposed to be the actor, so this actor, and the player
controller is supposed to be plugged into the player controller object reference here.
So if you come up to the target, hold down the control key, we can just shift the blue
pin from the top to the one below it. If we do our same for the disabled input,
now we can enable or disable the input when we enter. Now let's test this out.
But there's one more thing we need to do before we can, and that's add an event which is tied
to a key press. Now a quick way to do this is if you type in key and then z and select keyboard
event z. Now the z is not an ideal key for this, but I've selected z because it's easy to
select from from the box. And then with z selected, I'm going to come up into the
details, and you can see that there is a button next to the z key here. If I shift that button,
he'll turn orange, and then if I push the e button, this key input is going to change to e.
So you can now see that we have an e, an event, which is going to be triggered by the pressing
of the e key. Now I'm going to drag off of this, put another print string, and just have e pressed.
You know if I compile this and save and go back into the map and press play. Now if I press e
while I'm away from the door, nothing comes up in the way of a message. However, if I get close
to the door and press e, you can see at the top e pressed is fired. So that's what this does. When
I leave the the collision box, it's going to turn off the input from the keyboard,
and when I enter, this actor is going to be listening to the the keyboard. So that's it.
That is our first initial blueprint. Now in the next video, we will go on to get the door to
open and close using a timeline.